as nuclear fallout over the Pacific
continues the federal government has
declared Los Angeles uninhabitable the
base is four square miles all under NATO
command to be sure lieutenant we're
highly classified you are gonna be the
first man on Titan it's just an honor to
have been selected sir not gonna let you
down our resources have been depleted in
ten years
half the world's population will starve
today after planet will be uninhabitable
but there is one place gives us hope the
largest moon of Saturn
what if title could become a home you
will become enhanced humans most of you
will fail
some people will break during the
training your docking forced evolution
I'm talking survival of the species I've
studied you work I know what we're doing
here it's bigger than all of us this is
the last time someone was going to take
me for a while
I never thought I'd see something like
this he's changing
this is a space research it's criminal
I believe violent I want to finish I can
see everything
there is something alive inside of him
he's a soldier there's no going back
I mean I thought I already got this far
how can possibly what he is becoming
if we can't control it
all of us are dead
you